be careful about what school you put
them in if you're like oh i don't like
what that school's teaching my kids i
don't like their teacher that teacher is
teaching your kids for like nine to
three five days a week you don't like
that find a different one to be fair
public schools it's tricky and i didn't
grow up now nowadays it's worse but i
remember my dad took me out of class and
be like oh you're staying home this week
and i later found out those were the
more like the politically correct weeks
where guest speakers would come in and
teach you and my dad just like nah
staying home this week the kids aren't
gonna know anything that isn't told to
them i just find it funny that all these
people come and talk about
indoctrination and they say oh you want
to homeschool your kids or you want to
make your kid a christian you want to
indoctrinate them with those values and
it's like in a way yes not indoctrinate
but i want to give my kids these values
i don't care about what you think about
me leftists i want to push these values
on my kids to make them good people and
then if you send them to public school
then they're just indoctrinated by the
government so would i rather have them
be indoctrinated by me or indoctrinated
by you teacher it seems pretty obvious